la question est lorsque vous voulez
acheter un nouveau smartphone qu'est ce
que vous voulez qu'est ce que vous
voulez la chose qui va définir en
premier le choix ton smartphone ça va
être son budget si vous avez un budget
de 300 400 euros bien évidemment on peut
toujours vouloir regarder des
smartphones très haut de gamme mais on
est quand même loin de notre budget mais
malgré tout dans un budget de 300 à 400
euros
on va pas ne plus vouloir attendre
n'importe quoi ton smartphone donc la
question à se poser c'est vraiment celle
là qu'est ce que vous attendez du
smartphone que vous allez acheter qu'est
ce que vous voulez quelles sont les
choses hyper importante et quels sont
les points sur lequel vous êtes prêt à
faire des concessions parce qu'en
fonction du budget qu'on va vouloir
qu'on va pouvoir allouer à son
smartphone il va falloir un moment faire
des concessions
ça on garde dans un coin de notre tête
aujourd'hui je vous parlais d'un des
derniers smartphones de samsung c'est
celui là c'est le samsung galaxy à 42 5
g le nom se rallonge qui est le
successeur du samsung galaxy à 41 4 g on
disait par 4g parce qu'effectivement on
savait qu'ils étaient quand j'ai vu que
c'était la norme et comme là on est sûr
en tout nouveau smartphone est que ce
nouveau smartphone et 5 g ont dit qu'ils
les 5 g on s'inscrit vraiment dans la
cette ligne en fait qu'on retrouve
depuis le début de l'année 2020 avec
tout d'abord l'arrivée sur les
smartphones y plus haut de gamme de la
5g puis plus ça va plus la 5g arrive sur
les smartphone milieu de gamme d'entrée
de gamme la 5g et la salle j arrive
enfin arrivera en france
en 2021 pour l'instant elle arrive dans
nos smartphones mélange tout doucement
mais elle arrive il vous faut bien des
smartphones 5g quand vous allez pouvoir
avoir les abonnements samedi bref donc
on va parler de ce nouveau smartphone de
samsung on va regarder s'il intéresse on
va regarder surtout si une évolution par
rapport au samsung galaxy cas à 41
pardon 4g effectivement il ya la semaine
j'ai 100 m et au delà de la 5g
est ce qu'il ya de réelles innovations
est ce que ce smartphone est intéressant
et surtout est-ce qu'il est bien
positionné par rapport à la concurrence
un grand programme tout ça mais bien
évidemment et vous le savez vous
connaissez l'histoire je vous invite
tout d'abord à venir vous abonner pour
nous rejoindre on est bien tous ensemble
à regarder comme on est bien on est
drôlement bien pour vous abonner c'est
très facile vous cliquez sur le bouton
rouge situé juste en dessous ici si les
rouges c'est vous n'êtes toujours pas
abonné vous cliquez dessus vous
actionnez la cloche comme ça vous serez
identifié dès qu une prochaine vidéo
arrivera pour nous rejoindre et pour
qu'on soit bien tous ensemble on va se
situer un peu l'histoire à 41 à 42 à 41
à 42
on a un capteur en plus au niveau de la
photo ça c'est plutôt sympathique et
surtout on a un design que légèrement à
changer un smartphone qui sont tous plus
grands regardez ça la distance entre le
à 41 et le à 42 alors moi ce que j'aime
bien tout de suite c'est cette
différence que vous allez avoir je sais
pas si vous allez bien vous en rendre
compte vous avez toute cette partie là
avec plein de petits points stand à un
tout petit peu moins ici ou au cm²
encore un petit peu moins pour arriver
sur une zone qui est complètement lisse
il n'y a pas de points on est sur un dos
brillant malgré tout on est sur un dos
plastique on se retrouve avec ce petit
carré ces quatre capteurs ça sera un
très grand classique cette année bon
après au niveau du design et à l'indien
déconnant on reste sur des grand grand
grand grand classique haut parleurs
prise jack prix jack ça c'est pas mal
dans ce segment là de la recharge en usb
c'est ici tiroirs de cartes sim double
nano sim ou nano symplus carte microsd
le micro pour la réduction de bruit
bouton de volume le bouton pour
l'allumer pour l'éteindre et après rien
de bien surprenant avons trouvé votre
capteur d'empreintes digitales pour
déverrouiller extrêmement rapidement on
va donc retrouver ici une petite encoche
pas fait ça comme ça qui vient cueillir
votre caméra et ensuite vous avez un
petit menton moi quand on sera comme ça
je trouve plutôt sympathique
la prise en main est bonne il est un peu
plus loin comme je vous le disais que le
à 41 dans ce segment de prix le point
qui est toujours mis en avant par les
constructeurs c'est la batterie pour
vous apporter une très belle autonomie
ici samsung vous avez une batterie de
5000 milan perd heures avec un blog de
charge de 15 watts inclus on a donc ici
une nette évolution par rapport aux à 41
qui avait une batterie de trois mille
cinq cents millions terreur autre
évolution intéressante vous passé de 64
giga de stockage à 128 go de stockage
les performances sont qu'est ce la
dragonne 750 g g pour gaming on est sur
un processeur milieu de gamme de
qualcomm
on a 4 gigas de ram et pour une
expérience de gaming ça fera très très
bien la faire on a ici une dalle super
amoled signé samsung 36,6 pouces
résolution hd plus mes 6 ans par 720
pixels hd plus comment est ce que j'ai
pu passer d'un écran full hd plus sur un
samsung galaxy 1,41 à un écran hd + sera
samsung galaxy à 42 j'ai donc une perte
de résolution pour un smartphone qui va
quand même coûté plus cher même si
l'augmentation du prix est en partie due
5 g parce que là on revient dans notre
réflexion initiale qu'est ce qu'on
attend de notre smartphone qu'est-ce
qu'on veut notre smartphone
la première chose qu'on voit sur notre
smartphone c'est notre écran c'est ce
qu'on regarde le plus je vais pas vous
dire ici que la dalle n'est pas bonne ça
serait pas vrai et je la trouve plutôt
bien bien que trop saturé trop
flatteuses et pas beaucoup de points
pour venir corriger ça j'ai un mode
naturel qui va être un petit peu trop
palau un peu trop sans saveur donc je
choisirais un mode vif qui me semblera
mieux convenir en tout cas un affichage
qui me paraît être en tout cas de
qualité par rapport à ce que je peux
attendre une dalle super amoled mais
même si on a une dalle qui est plutôt
pas mal dans l'ensemble je trouve ça un
peu dérangeant de me dire que le modèle
de la génération actuelle va coûter plus
cher qu'aux modèles de la génération
d'avant et que je vais venir perdre en
résolution au niveau de mon écran si
j'avais eu dès le départ sera samsung
galaxy à 41 un écran avec une résolution
hd + ça m'aurait pas surpris d'en
trouver avec une résolution hd plus mais
de passer d'un full hd plus à un âge de
plus ça fait un peu râler malgré ça
l'expérience multimédia quand même
plutôt bonne mais malgré tout j'ai un
son qui est assez fort grâce au petit
haut parleur mono que j'ai sur le côté
pour me regarder films séries ce que
vous voulez ça fera la faire comme vous
le disais on ait une prise jack donc
plutôt bien pour les personnes qui ont
un casque filaire pour venir profiter
d'une expérience au casque avec un fil
vous avez également de me to 5.0 pour
venir connecter vos galaxie buzz live
par exemple par contre toujours en tout
cas toujours très très cool chez samsung
c'est l'expérience logiciel avec one way
ça c'est vraiment très complet très très
très agréable à chaque fois je vous
parle d'un smartphone de samsung je vous
parle de one day l'expérience est bien
que ce soit pour avoir un accès très
rapide et très compréhensible à tous vos
paramètres c'est une des expériences les
plus abouties aujourd'hui sur android
tandis qu'oddo vous n'avez pas moins de
quatre capteurs le capteur que vous
allez retrouver ici en haut à gauche
c'est un ultra grand-angle 8 mégapixels
f 2.2 qui est un champ de vision de 123
degrés en dessous juste là c'est votre
capteur principal c'est un 48 mégapixels
qui ouvre à f 1.8 ici en haut sur le
côté vous allez avoir un capteur de
maquereaux 5 mégapixels f 2.4 et si
c'est votre capteur de profondeur pour
votre effet beaucoup pour votre mode
portrait 5 mégapixels f 2.4 tandis qu'à
l'avant vous avez une caméra de 20
mégapixels qui ouvre à f 2.2 on a ici un
zoom numérique x 10 et vous pouvez faire
de la vidéo jusqu'en 4k à 30 images par
seconde calmez vous
calmez vous calmez vous je vous vois
venir vous voyez samsung vous voyez
quatre caméras vous vous dites waouh ça
va envoyer du bois alors j'ai pas y'a
que s'envolent pas de bois je veux juste
te dire qu'ici on parle d'un smartphone
milieu de gamme on est sur le cac 40 2,5
g on n'est pas sur le samsung galaxy s
20 plus s20 ultra on est vraiment dans
un autre segment ont pas retrouvé malgré
tout le savoir-faire de samsung mais on
n'ira pas aussi loin que sur les
smartphones ultra premium
alors ça c'est un truc un peu à la mode
en ce moment de venir vous mettre quatre
caméras en vous disant hey regardez vous
avez un super smartphone avec pas moins
de quatre caméras c'est génial il n'y a
pas que samsung qui vous fait ça à tous
les constructeurs sa ligne parce que
c'est un standard
si l'un vous propose quatre caméras et
que l'autre vous mais deux caméras vous
allez vous dire pourquoi est ce que
j'irai payer pour deux caméras alors que
et à la concurrence va avoir quatre
caméras vous iriez donc sur celui qui en
a le plus même si dans l'ensemble vous
n'êtes pas vous en servir et que ça ne
sert strictement à rien c'est un peu
l'idée c'est toute cette stratégie
marketing où on vient pousser les
évolutions vont bien pousser les usages
est aussi un grand nombre de capteurs
sont globalement on va strictement rien
faire vous avez deux capteurs vous allez
potentiellement vraiment utilisé ici le
premier ça va être votre capteur
principal
ça va être sur lesquels vous allez faire
toutes vos photos donc c'est normal que
vous veniez l'utiliser ok on regarde le
résultat dans quelques instants
le deuxième ça va être de temps en temps
lui très grand-angle vous avez un très
joli paysage que voulait venir
immortalisé vous avez un bâtiment vous
manque un peu de recul vous passez sur
l'ultra grand-angle pourquoi pas mais
qu'est ce que vous allez faire une fois
de plus et je les dis depuis longtemps
je ne dis pas que là un jeu je fais mon
vieux râleur mais qu'est ce que vous
allez faire un capteur de maquereaux
qu'est-ce qu'on va venir shooter de la
macro je pars en une fois plus on
repense à ces usages réfléchissez à vos
usages vous acheter un smartphone pour
des usages
est ce que ça vous arrive est déjà
d'aller prendre des photos en macro en
tête que vous allez me dire non parce
que j'avais pas la fonctionnalité que du
coup j'avais pas le faire mais je peux
vous assurer qu en ayant un capteur d'un
croc si vous n'allez pas pour autant à
les prendre en photo les insectes ou les
fleurs ou je ne sais quoi ou votre
boudoul je vois pas trop l'intérêt
le capteur profondeur c'est la même
chose à quel moment on prend souvent des
photos avec un autre portrait est ce
qu'on veut faire souvent des choses un
peu créative avec un flou d'arrière plan
je pas extrêmement convaincu alors
peut-être que vous allez le faire des
heures dites le moi vous en commentaire
à ce que c'est des usages que vous avez
est ce que vous pourriez le faire
la macro et mode portrait expliquez moi
ça parce que moi je suis pas trop trop
convaincu bon je vous montre le résultat
des photos voilà de la photo prise en
macro c'est pas mal mais je trouve que
le résultat est pas complètement dingos
caisse
venir ajouté avec ma d'accrocs surtout
qu'ici il n'y a aucune stabilisation
donc dès qu'on bouge c'est mort je suis
pas hyper emballer les photos par contre
prises avec le capteur principal marche
vraiment très bien et c'est un peu
flatteur un peu saturé on retrouve la
patte samsung la qualité est au rendez
vous dès qu'on passe sur l'ultra grand
angle et bien écoutez je vous conseille
quand même plutôt pas trop trop mal on
va voir un peu de bruine qui sur le côté
voyez c'est loin d'être parfait
ça fait le boulot on vient se rapprocher
avec le x 2 on récupère déjà un peu de
bruit on le voit dans le ciel ici le x 4
c'est pas génial et alors le faux 10e
n'en parlons pas on commence notre
principal c'est très très très bien on
va bien tous les nuages on voit bien là
où on voit bien les feuilles rien et
crâne et rien n'est trop sombre ça
marche bien
l' ultra grand-angle fera le boulot mais
faut pas trop trop lui en demander parce
qu'on le voit ici on a un peu de bruit
les tendances un petit peu alice et
c'est pas parfait mais il va plus on
n'est pas non plus sur un photophone
fois de pourquoi pas mais il faut y
aller avec parcimonie x 4 c'est pas
terrible ça lisse on oublié le faux
disent je cède ma part que c'est que ce
truc c'est vraiment très très horrible
la caméra de cellfish from boulot
sensiblement ça vient un petit peu le
50e votre port près ça vient quand même
dans l'ensemble pas trop mal des tours
et ça vient lisser les visages
il ya un vrai gros traitement logiciel
là dessus et ici on est sur un
smartphone qui coûte 3 179 euros
je reste toujours un peu dubitatif avec
ce smartphone parce que autant je trouve
cool
j'aime bien le côté esthétique que
samsung a bien travaillé j'aime bien le
côté avec le dégradé au niveau du nombre
de petits points que vous allez avoir il
ya un côté très sympa l'appareil photo
ici c'est un très grand standard on le
retrouve aujourd'hui l'écran bien fin on
est un smartphone qui dans l'ensemble
est plutôt bien mais je retourne
toujours à ma réflexion initiale de me
dire qu'est ce que je veux sur mon
smartphone est la première chose que je
veux sur un smartphone
c'est un écran qui me plaisent un écran
de qualité j'ai l'impression qu'une
régression entre le à 41 et le à 42 au
niveau de l'écran au niveau de l'écran
la batterie est plus grosse et
performances seront très bonnes c'est
vraiment niveau de l'écran
parce qu'une fois de plus je me mets à
la place du consommateur et là vous fait
une comparaison de samsung la samsung
sur une évolution de génération mais si
je la regardais ailleurs ce qui se passe
à la concurrence ce qu'on fera en
général quand on va acheter un produit
eh bien je me rends compte qu'en fait
samsung n'est pas forcément complètement
dans les clous je prends l'exemple de
xiaomi avec son me disent tu es pro qui
coûte 50 euros 2
- que le samsung galaxy à 42 je vais
avoir le même processeur je vais avoir
sensiblement la même batterie 4800 d'un
millier en paire eur/chf avoir un bloc
de charge un peu plus puissants 33 voix
contre 15 watts bon voilà hockey change
pas bien l'histoire mais un poil plus
mais surtout d'avoir un écran de 6
pouces full hd plus avec un taux de
rafraîchissement de 120 hertz brouillée
quand on se met à la place du
consommateur on ca ou est-ce que je vais
aller alors je peux pas vous dire que ce
smartphone ne l'aï pas bien c'est pas
vrai je trouve bien je trouve
intéressant je suis toujours un peu
embêté pour ses histoires l'écran mais
au niveau de l'expérience globale et
bien mes sens que pour la partie
logicielle ou un nuage je ne pourrais
que vous le recommander mais si vous
regardez ce qui se passe du côté de chez
shiomi avec notamment son me disent tu
es pro et yachir oui mais également
d'autres marques
eh bien voyez la question se pose donc
si vous aimez samsung si vous êtes
vraiment rassuré par la marque samsung
si vous avez un produit éco système
samsung et si vous aimez la partie
logicielle de samsung allez-y foncez il
est vraiment bien sûr tout est prêt pour
la 5g si maintenant c'est pas ça qui
motive réellement et que ce que vous
voulez vraiment c'est les meilleurs spec
a quasiment le même tarif peut-être que
c'est pas sûr qu'il vous faut peut-être
dit pas ce que vous en pensez en bas on
commentaire est-ce que ce samsung galaxy
à 42 5 g vous fait de l'oeil ou pas vu
que moi moi je trouve bien mais voilà du
bémol quand des bisous beaucoup d'amour